SGA you're not shooting the ball
particularly well but you still play the
right way ER possession take me through
what you saw there throughout T night
yeah whatever it takes to get a w um we
have an identity that we want to play
through uh and the more we can do so
every night the better team we will be
and we know that um and that's that's
the front of most of our minds well all
of our minds on the team every
possession every quarter every game we
just want to play to our identity and
play in our comfort zone speaking of
that comfort zone talking to coach dags
before the game the average NBA fan
don't know who he is they say this
team's too young but you continue to
play the right way and share the
basketball like you do yeah to be honest
we're not worried about what people say
about us um we have goals we have
aspirations we want to be a really good
basketball team and we know there's
certain things you have to do to be so
um and that's what we're focused on
every day every time we come into
practice every time it's a game day
that's what we're focused on being a
good basketball team and when you see a
guy like Isaiah Joe I seen you guys that
shoot around get you know going against
each other shooting the basketball
tonight he's 7 and seven from
three-point Lane yeah it's another
Isaiah Joe KN um kid Works super hard
he's talented uh we expect things like
this from him so we're not super
surprised but he deserves it for sure
last one for you check the way he plays
so confident so poised how big is that
to have him for the long run this season
yeah it's huge he brings so so many
elements to our team um he's versatile
on both ends of the floor can switch can
play multiple positions kid Works super
hard um he's going to be really special
for sure keep doing what you do we'll do
baby good to see you all right man my
man s baby Day game as
usual